lo que nos están pidiendo es que
restamos simplifiquemos y escribamos la
respuesta como una fracción mixta y al
igual que cuando estamos sumando números
mixtos podemos restar primero las partes
enteras y después restar las fracciones
o podemos convertir todo el número a una
fracción impropia y restar las
fracciones impropias pero pues empecemos
primero por la parte en la que vamos a
restar primero los enteros y después la
fracción propia y bueno solo para
recordarlo esto este el número cinco y
cinco octavos lo que es es un entero
cinco sumado de la fracción cinco
octavos y lo mismo pasa con este dos y
un quinto lo voy a poner en morado es el
número entero dos más la fracción un
quinto ok y bueno aquí no se nos olvide
que se está restando
voy a ponerlo en azul
aquí este menos afecta a todo lo que
está dentro del paréntesis ok tenemos
que usar la propiedad distributiva
tenemos que restar tanto el 2 como el un
quinto y entonces lo que obtenemos es 5
+ 5 octavos que ya tenemos esto y ahora
si vamos a usar la propiedad
distributiva para meter el menos dentro
del paréntesis menos 2 y después otra
vez menos por más de menos menos un
quinto
y ahora sí ya podemos reacomodar esta
suma de factores y entonces lo que nos
va a quedar es cinco menos dos más cinco
octavos menos un quinto y este pedacito
de acá la resta de los enteros pues nos
queda 5 menos 23 y tenemos que sumarle
lo que nos dé de la resta de estas
fracciones propias pero vamos a hacer
esta resta en este espacio
ok tenemos 5 octavos y le queremos
restar
un quinto cuando queremos restar dos
fracciones al igual que cuando queremos
sumar dos fracciones tenemos que tener
el mismo denominador y bueno como 8 es
distinto de 5 estas dos fracciones no
tienen el mismo denominador entonces
pues vamos a encontrar unas fracciones
que sean equivalentes a estas pero que
tengan el mismo denominador y para eso
tenemos que utilizar la descomposición
en números primos de cada uno de estos
para poder encontrar el mínimo común
múltiplo y bueno factor izando este 8 en
sus factores primos pues tenemos que 8
es 2 por 4 y bueno este ya es un factor
primo y el 4 se factor y está en 2 por 2
y bueno por otro lado el 5 el 5 en sí ya
es un número primo entonces ya está en
su descomposición en primos como un 5
así es que el mínimo común múltiplo de
estos dos números tiene que tener un 5
312 osea que el mínimo común múltiplo va
a ser 5 por 2 por 2 por 2 que resulta
ser exactamente lo mismo que 5 por 8 que
además es 40 y este mínimo común
múltiplo va a ser el nuevo denominador
de estas dos fracciones ahora para
convertir esta fracción en esta fracción
tuvimos que multiplicar el denominador
por un 5 entonces también tenemos que
multiplicar el numerador por un 5 ok
aquí de aquí para acá vamos a
multiplicar todo por 5 entre 5 y 8 por 5
ya nos da 40 y arriba tenemos que
multiplicar 5 por 5 que nos da 25 y para
pasar de esta fracción a esta fracción
tenemos que multiplicar el denominador
por 18 entonces para estar multiplicando
por uno en lugar de multiplicar por
cualquier otra cosa tenemos que
multiplicar también el numerador por un
8 entonces 5 por 8 nos da 40 y el
numerador que es 1 por 8 nos va a dar
nada más
y ahora sí como estas dos fracciones
tienen exactamente el mismo denominador
entonces ya podemos simplemente restar
el numerador y lo que nos queda es 25
menos 8 17 y en el denominador 40 ok 5
octavos menos un quinto es exactamente
igual a 17 40 vos entonces aquí lo que
tenemos que poner son 17 40 2 y además
17 y 40 son primos relativos osea no
tienen factores en común ningún divisor
distinto de uno que divida 40 también
divide a 17 y viceversa entonces esta
fracción ya no se puede simplificar más
y entonces ya terminamos nada más nos
falta escribir esto como un número mixto
eso se escribe de esta forma 317 40 vos
si no se hubiera quedado por aquí un
signo de menos entonces tendríamos que
hacer otro relajo tendría este entero
que prestar un 1 para que se restará con
esta fracción y nos quedara en forma del
número mixto pero por el momento esta es
la respuesta